une remise en question générale face aux
députés c'est l'impression qu'a donnée
ce matin l'audition des responsables de
l'institut national du cancer avec
d'abord un message clair sur le cancer
de la prostate en martinique
on s'affole pour rien trop de diagnostic
parmi les personnes qui ont un psa total
supérieur à 4 nanogrammes par millilitre
3 sur 10 ont un cancer de la prostate et
sept sur dix n'ont en réalité pas de
cancer de la prostate
il y a toujours eu plus de dosage de psa
aux antilles qu'en métropole on comprend
bien pourquoi
et d'ailleurs que dans les autres
départements d'outre-mer quel que soit
l'âge de même il y a toujours eu
davantage de biopsie dans les antilles
et en particulier en martinique
le président a même remis en cause la
validité de l'étude de référence sur les
relations entre cancer de la prostate et
chlordécone car prostate tout en la
qualifiant en même temps d'excellentes
études l'étude karuprostate comparer
deux populations toutes les deux exposés
évidemment puisque tout le monde est
exposé à la guadeloupe des malades
étaient témoins et qui s'est trouvée que
par malchance les deux populations
n'étaient pas comparables sur un certain
nombre de facteurs de risque majeurs de
cancer de la prostate
l'inca a renoncé au financement d'une
autre étude mahdi prostate quand
l'actuel ministre de la santé
agnès buzyn en était présidente elle a
donc justifié son choix par des
faiblesses scientifique des études
mais comme l'ont souligné les députés
dix ans se sont écoulés depuis le
travail de l'inserm
simplement je veux mettre en évidence
cette commission si sa responsabilité
que carlu prostate a été réalisé aux
commandes et au milieu en 2010 d'accord
nous sommes un cas l'année 2019
ça fait neuf ans franchement les choses
vont peut être changer le président de
l'unc a annoncé avoir enfin demander le
relèvement du chlordécone dans la liste
des cancérigènes à l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
il a également annoncé la mise en place
d'un collège d'experts pour prouver le
caractère cancérigène mais sans
assurance sur son financement